[Music]
chrissy teigen is ready for baby number
two we're so happy it's been really
exciting and fun the 31 year old model
stuns on the cover of in styles November
issue inside the mag the brunette beauty
who's been open about her fertility
struggles says she and husband John
Legend will start trying for a second
baby in the coming months using IVF my
little boys next for sure really I mean
I don't know but we have one oh nice so
fingers I assume with Chrissy explains
that the couple initially extracted 20
embryos and only three were determined
to work for her body the first didn't
the second is their one-year-old
daughter Luna and the third will be
transferred to her womb soon I did feel
sexier when I was pregnant though I will
say that a lip sync battle co-host knows
that with a second pregnancy comes the
possibility of postpartum depression
which she experienced after having Luna
Chrissy said quote I have really good
days in really bad days and I don't tend
to talk about the really bad days but I
would hate for people to think those
days didn't exist Chrissy's rocked
through it all her hubby John she
sweetly gushed
I'm much luckier to have John's
personality in my life than he is to
have mine John seems equally smitten we
realized we had such a connection and
then it blossomed into a marriage and a
baby
[Music]
you
[Music]